[Music]
we're here today to talk about cloud
costs and reporting on them and
hopefully aligning that with your what
services you're delivering for your
business or your customers the agenda
today so I need to go over some things
with you to make sure that everyone
understands the sort of building blocks
that we have organizational options
about how we how we set up our GCP
infrastructure then we'll go over what's
available for tooling out there and then
we can get into some strategies towards
the end of the presentation about how we
can apply those and help you sort of
line up your costs so i'm jeremy
director of cloud infrastructure for
augusto augusto's been a GCP partner for
at least 10 years since G suite was
first released
augusto sort of started the Google
practice there and divested the rest of
the business and since then we've been
strictly focused on Google technologies
so my my role and infrastructure is to
do everything that's not app dev or G
suite or Chrome for the most part so we
help customers all day every day with
with aligning their costs and Identity
Management and implementing these
various architectures okay so I wanted
to start out with a couple things that I
observe as I work with our customers
first of all is that that your
consumption everyone is in their own
state right but consumption starts at
zero of course and ramps up so I'm
trying to get to the point that it can
surprise you sometimes right
organizations want predictable cost they
want to know hey what's my bill gonna be
next month right but cloud isn't really
designed for that ultimately because you
pay for what you use it's not supposed
to be a predictable model but our
companies still want predictable so we
try to sort of meet in the middle and
estimate and use reporting tools and in
and it put the quote down on the bottom
and number two
there get this under control like it's
something that we hear from our
customers maybe maybe you get started
and you kind of fly under the radar for
for your consumption and then eventually
you hit a dollar amount that that raises
some alarms within your organization and
hopefully before we get there we can
have some reporting that shows you like
why did we get there like just because
it doesn't mean we're out of our costs
are out of control
is what what the point I'm trying to say
is like sometimes customers just haven't
spent any time on reflecting back to
their business outside of the IT
organization or whoever is responsible
for primary GCP administration sometimes
they just haven't shared the right
information with the business so it's a
lot of why we're here
only three is there a lot of different
people and you're in your organization
who may be interested in this data and
they need different stuff EPP owners
business units need different stuff than
the finance department then maybe if you
have central IT not everybody does but
maybe if you have central IT they need
different things and executives one want
their view as well sort of high level
way of looking at it so we'll cover tool
sets that will help us for all of those
different people and in build out a
strategy that that sort of is proactive
here so let's go through some
definitions hopefully this isn't too
basic for you but I want to make sure
everybody understood in GCP we have orgs
so that's your augusto comm for example
for me we can have any number of them
right it's a DNS domain they're free
sometimes we want more than one
sometimes we want one some isolated for
GCP sometimes we want it to be our
primary domain but we have the concept
of an org node inside that used to be
projects and projects have resources
some resources being compute engine VMs
kubernetes named cloud sequel what any
of your different technologies and in
between there are folders so folders are
not super old they haven't existed
forever and we're constantly finding new
ways to do them
and folders are something that's been
really helpful for us recently
so simply projects can reside in folders
but don't don't have to so I put a
couple of data points here I think
Google when they designed them would
primarily tell you that folders are
therefore I am enforcement point so you
can set up some permissions on a folder
and then every project you create in
there will inherit those permissions
right a lot like a folder structure
you'd find on a file system but we're
finding other ways to use them in terms
of reporting as well
projects are completely separate from
each other but report into the same
folder resources that are part of the
project like I mentioned and and then
important point is that you don't have
to have a project in a folder so if you
stand up and empty or ignored in GCP I'm
sure plenty of you've seen this but hey
I don't have a folder I don't have to
have them at all
so then outside of all of that tree that
I just drew there are billing accounts a
lot of you may know your billing account
as being something in your org but it
doesn't have to be in there and you
don't have to have just one billing
account but a billing account is simply
a bill it's gonna come as its own own
bill and the bill is linked to projects
and so you can default things right but
generally speaking the bill has projects
the billing account has projects
associated with it
yeah and you can disable billing on the
individual project level as well
important to note that prop billing
accounts also have their own iam
permission sets so you can you can blend
in like some folder permissions along
with billing account permissions to come
up with a strategy to to make sure the
right people are assigning billing to
the right place ok switching gears a
little bit our labels when when we come
into cost reporting a lot of people jump
to the concept of labels immediately
it's not our only strategy but it's a
super-important one okay so you can you
can label lots of things for the
purposes of a billing information you
you link them with a resource so that's
a simplest level GCE
VM has a key/value pair that you could
assign to it that is that is the label
right so we can have a bunch of them per
you can have a permission set so 64
labels per resource really billing
specific related here I have a couple
example use cases in a minute but labels
based on on a team or cost center are
super common way to report on billing
right like that's kind of one of the
default ways that that Google might look
at them being used here you go a laundry
list of things that can be labeled
probably not complete but think of
anything anything that that bills that
generates costs as a SKU associated with
them can be labeled I think it's
probably important I don't think I cover
it in the next slide I think it's
probably important to tell you that
project lis projects can be labeled as
well that's a newer functionality but
that label doesn't show up in the
billing data so it's not like an
inheritance thing I've seen people kind
of assume that hey I label my project
and I might use that for various
automation reasons but I can't look at
that label for the project when I look
at billing for say GCE it doesn't an
instance wouldn't inherit the label okay
so you'll see stuff VM instances images
persistent disk snapshots bigquery even
individual queries cloud sequel all the
major products have support for labels
here's some example things that you
might apply to a resource an owner a
team an environment production dev test
whatever an app name server type OS
image and so they're they're their use
cases it's strictly for billing you
might apply some kind of security policy
or some kind of automation to that you
might use it for scripting to find all
the VMS with this certainly will and do
something with them so but I mean for
the purpose of this conversation they're
there to help you report gke super
popular this is a little bit in the
weeds but I wanted to bring it up
because I think it's important
coming up here in a little bit to
understand that gke has namespaces and
it can assign labels to them but in the
billing data I can't see I can't see the
labels outside of the cluster right so
you you assign the the the labels from a
billing perspective at the cluster level
only so you'll see if you have a bunch
of stuff in a rather large cluster look
like a jumbled together mix multi-tenant
people in particular will will will need
to come up with a strategy for how to
deal with this okay so that kind of sets
a stage of the different building blocks
we have within GCP so now now I wanted
to go over the the what kind of data can
we get at right so so at the billing
account level we can export into
bigquery right and I'd assume everyone's
familiar with bigquery it's a platform
based database that's that's ready to
use we can go into our billing account
settings and set up to export billing
data to whatever data set we choose okay
so if we were to have more than one
billing account we would end up with
separate data sets they wouldn't be
mixed together at a minimum they'd be in
separate tables so I wanted to give you
a little bit about what's in there
because it becomes really important to
understand that bigquery billing data is
is so so let me back up your your
billing account then at the end of every
month you'll receive a CSV file and the
CSV file will have for every project
I'll have every single SKU that you're
using and the number of units in the
bill and the dollar amount associated
with that okay so that's at this really
kind of high level glossy view the
bigquery data is not that the bigquery
data trickles in throughout the month
throughout the day you'll have I don't
know thousands thousands of rows that
show up in there throughout the
throughout the month as you're reporting
so I kind of go over a few of the few of
the different items that are in there so
there'll be a usage start and end time
for every single row
it'll associate with an invoice month so
the invoice months and bigquery do add
up if you do sums on it and you look at
at the month it will add up to exactly
down to the penny to your bill
a project of course is is associated
with it a service so so compute engine
is a service cloud storage as a service
within a service or SKUs okay so
persistent disk for example is a SKU
that falls within compute engine so
there's I included a link to the SKUs
but it's like a crazy number of SKUs now
we talked about folders folder data
shows up in bigquery in the ancestry
numbers is what the the columns called
that will be in the form of an
organization and then separated by slash
will be your full folder path so you
could have up to five things in there
right with four folders and inside an
org important to note those are numbers
if you look inside the GCP console and
you explore your resources you'll see
you'll see numbers
it's an identifier number and you'll
need to look that up if you're doing any
reporting on it so that that that data
is in their labels key value pairs or
nested data that's in their location as
in zone region country whatever the
resources whatever the appropriate thing
is they're like cloud storage might show
up as a as a country versus a VM would
show up in a region and its own and then
usage costs and credits so it'll have a
unit it'll have a dollar amount for the
cost and then credits are important to
note as you're looking through whatever
billing reporting data you're looking at
is the credits are like sustained use
discount will show up as a credit for
example so SKU has a list price and you
know x it ends up multiplying by the
second throughout the month and then
halfway through the month you start to
receive a discount that discount shows
up as the form of a credit so you have
to add them together to get your total
cost for for that particular for that
particular role
okay so this this conversation is
important to bring up the main tool you
have to look at this data is writing
your council billing counsel billing
reports no setup required you just log
in and can see your your billing reports
I'm sure all of you have you can group
you can you can view this data by a
number of different things right so you
can filter by date range project product
SKU labels all the above one thing
that's not in there are folders I don't
know if that's coming or not but it's
not in there today so it's a really
detailed way to look at something you
could use this reporting to say how much
paid OS licenses do I have for last
month right in this project for example
that's in there by looking at the SKU
data and and you also can group that
data together so you could look at like
hey how much did that project cost
pretty much you can explore your data in
any number of ways that you want to it's
a super powerful tool and really good
for for GCP administrators to use our
experience has been that as we get away
from people who use GCP on a daily basis
the less they really would want to go in
there and navigate into that and we
that's where we use separate reporting
for those kind of personas so your GCP
admins are gonna be totally fine
figuring out whatever they need to my
one of my primary ways to look when
questions come up is to just log in the
billing billing reporting and go look at
it so that that's like the the base to
build off of from a product perspective
data studio is included with GCP data
studio connects to bigquery and numerous
other data sources but for the purpose
of this it'll hook up to date to a
bigquery and you can use it as a visual
visualization tool and the only thing
you pay for is whatever bigquery cost
that you have and so you know bigquery
is super cheap for when you're just
looking at small data so it's like
billing data it'll you know you're
probably looking at usage and the
pennies range so it kind of flies under
the radar there and it's pretty much
ends up being a free reporting tool for
you to build off of I think another
important thing to say about data studio
is you can feed it a table and you can
use the UI to design
design your queries and you don't end up
knowing you're making queries like you
don't have to write sit down and write
sequel here to make this happen at the
end I have a link to a github repo
that'll help you with some queries and
we we use a view to drive our our data
studio because we want to expose folder
data by by name so I include a little
helper table there that help our table
then has your folder numbers and names
and it does that linked together and
presents the right folder name for you
and then I include some scripts on how
to how to gather that data g-cloud in
PowerShell scripts that'll help you do
that when we're talking about
visualization there's no reason to say
that it has to be native studio though
if your organization has whatever other
data presentation visualization tools
that's cool many of them hook up to
bigquery it's very popular so it's like
most of the major players already have
support for bit for bigquery so you
don't have to necessarily use data
studio but this is the one included in
GCP and it's the one we we go with and
it also has Google auth built right into
it so we can we can control who can see
it and we can share it just like we're
used to with our business that's driven
by gee sweet brand-new I think it might
have been formally released yesterday it
was in beta form and we've been using it
for quite a while is the sheets data
connector so it's Google sheets data
connector for bigquery and we can run we
can write a query plop it in just like
you see in the screenshot there and then
are we we have our accounting people run
their own queries and so they can pull
up a month and summarize the data
however we decide it in the query and
then they have immediate access to that
at the end of the month for for
accounting people they seem to really
love tabular data
okay so everything we've said here
doesn't address the fact that people
want how much did that VM cost me it's
something that comes up all the time
okay so there's the main way I would
tell you to probably do that would be to
label your VM I think it's way faster
than what I'm showing here but I wanted
to tell you that the spot to see usage
data per VM is set up inside each
project in compute engine and it'll
export to CSV only okay so we could pull
together our own reporting if we wanted
to
that'll go look at the units of the data
that we see here so it'll be a whole
bunch of rows inside the sheet one for
each object and it'll show you how many
seconds did I use how many how many
bytes seconds of RAM did I use or how
many seconds of CPU did I use and I can
use that at the end of the month to
calculate to calculate how much that VM
costs no that's not there's no there's
no tool sets beyond that that I'm aware
of to help you actually figure that cost
out so it's a little bit painful to do
you need to look up the SKU and do the
math yourself not the end of the world
but it's a bit of work and that's why
I'd recommend if you do need that data
to go into a labeling strategy to try to
achieve it or you know most of our
customers who are talking about that I
usually kind of turn the conversation
around a little bit and try to focus
less on the individual instances and
focus more on services so that you know
this the the concept of the of the of
the VM being a permanent thing that
exists forever isn't it's not very fluid
right and so it's much more cloud-like
to look at things as a look at things as
a dynamic resource they come the VMS
come and go and they're all part of
delivering whatever service and that's
more of the level we want to look at
things
I can go back it won't go back so
important to know what sometimes people
ask Oh what what network traffic that I
have per VM and that's a legit need that
you have and it's in there you can look
at the inter and intra zone and you can
also look at inbound load balancers as
well super cool I haven't had much
chance to play play with this here I
wanted to bring it up probably a bit of
a hike but there's a session immediately
after this one in in Moscone on this
specific feature that was just released
okay so gke can dump to bigquery usage
data so in the same data set we could
take a G's gke cluster and then we could
look at namespaces and we mentioned
namespaces earlier there we can look at
namespaces or labels inside the gke
cluster and we can join that with the
billing data so it's just performance
data but we join that with the billing
data and you can see here Google
provided an example data studio report
and they do have a bunch of example data
studio stuff to go look at out there if
you do some searches and maybe on github
I can include some links I haven't done
that yet but I could probably do that to
direct you right to the report so you
don't have to hunt around for them but
this seems like it's gonna be a really
cool way to build up some additional
reporting that we didn't have this was
first announced I think late January in
a blog post ok so moving on to some
strategies I feel like at this point
we've kind of laid the groundwork you
understand the building blocks that we
have on how to organize GCP and then
where we can get to our data so it's
like what do we do with that now how do
we set it up right with customers every
time they come to us want to know how
many orgs should I have
how many projects should I have should I
do everything in one big gke cluster all
those sort of questions and I'm not
going to tell you that that we have the
answers because it's super situational
customers want best practices and I
think we're we're at the point where we
could say we have some best practices
but it's not going to be a recipe for
you that tells you exactly what you need
it's more of some general guidance and
everybody's just so unique in the
platform's so vast that there's no way
to tell you exactly how
should do that so I wanted to come back
to this right so consumption builds over
time so let's proactively build some
reports for our people so that they
don't become surprised by the bill right
so that we don't have people who think
our costs aren't under control right I
mean the only people I think of that I
described as not under control are
people who have lost resources out there
and that's a real thing right VM sprawl
is what we used to call it back in the
day in the VMware world where we've
stranded
maybe disk files for example write
persistent disks I ran into a customer
the other day twelve grand a month worth
of SSDs sitting there detached that
stuff happens those are the people that
I think are under control besides that
it's usually a visibility issue about we
don't really know what's going on out
there because you haven't really showed
me much data and I get a bill at the end
of the month and it's X number of
dollars and it's not where I want it to
be and I'm kind of frustrated that I
have to pay that so it's important that
our different personas there on the
right have their have their view of the
world and can kind of explore that data
and I think it helps build a lot of
trust all right so we've presented two
main ways to summarize that data labels
and folders so I laid out a couple of
points related to each you know the
labels are super flexible they're built
into all the existing reporting tools
are very natural to use the main concern
we have with people go in with an only
labeling strategy is that you have to be
detailed enough to get the labels there
I mean it's that easy
in it if you're doing manual processes
it gets missed so from a process
perspective we always say we need to
automate that right we need to provision
with terraform we need to use any kind
of automation tool or people forget
things especially little tiny details
like that folders are a way to
automatically summarize the data right
as long as projects get put in the right
place they're gonna be reported on
correctly but the concerns sometimes
where they don't work out is I am rules
are not are not in line so there's
several reasons why you might say like
might say that that cost need to be
spread out differently because I can't
have that set of iam rules on a folder
like it doesn't it doesn't add up in the
end so that's where that's where that
doesn't work and also tell you folders
aren't super flexible right they're
high-level roll-up so I think the next
one goes into I called this enterprise
call it corporate call it what nonsense
right so I gave an example here you can
see IT has a folder finance as a folder
HR has a folder sales has a folder there
are apps apps as in projects in in those
folders and it's a very quick way to say
alright so someone running systems for
finance only has project creator access
at the finance folder level and we have
a lot of customers who are doing this
and then we know exactly that that
finance department is gonna end up
paying the bill for that consumption it
will allows for three levels of layers
of folders I covered that earlier
is it Cori do you remember is it three
or four I thought it was four yeah yeah
thanks thanks it was a typo then that's
what I thought so yeah you can do some
roll-ups if you need to if you need to
break out like finance into individual
apps or dev test prod or whatever other
folders beneath that for operational
reasons you certainly can and we we we
typically almost always roll up the
costs into that top level folder and
that's what you'll find all of my
scripts that are out there for clear all
the queries that are out there roll up
to the top level but it's easy enough to
adjust to so that's kind of a typical
corporate environment that's like
general purpose GCP not real focused on
deploying a specific product some sample
some sample view here or screenshot of
of of data studio so we've got a number
of folders there in that drop-down so
that's a filter this is kind of our
standard report it'll look just very
similar to one you can pull down from
google has a date range has a list of
folders you'll see the summary dollar
amounts there on the right
and then and then once you once you dial
in that cost you can see then all the
different graphics will change so that
that stuff's all super easy to do in
data studio as well you you set it up as
a filter control and you tell it which
filter what column you want to filter on
you know I think I forgot to mention one
thing to in in bigquery bigquery
supports date partitioning and that's a
way to limit how much data we're
querying
so bigquery is charged by by how much
data you query that's kind of generally
how your how your cost is and so in here
is date partitions are filled out by the
by the bigquery data export and this
control will use that in data studio to
filter it so say you had a gig of data
or whatever number of data that covered
all of time right and if you just press
search without a filter on it it will
scan all that data and you'll pay for
that whole query but in this case I said
February 1 to February 28 na that that
adjusted the the date partition filter
and so I only paid for maybe it's ten
Meg of that data or whatever the number
is
it's the subset of data so I don't need
to pay for it all and it does kind of
keep things more affordable not a huge
concern in for most people and they're
in their footprint of their billing data
because it is small enough but still
important to note that that's easy
enough to do and it's built in the
platform so so why not use it and save a
little bit of money so yeah that's
that's the kind of view the standard
standard report that you pull down from
Google has has broken down by resource
by project by you could explore in a
compute engine and you could see for
example how much you're paying for a
persistent disk there's a number of ways
to break that down
and so here's then the similar kind of
concept to present that in sheets view
so the bigquery connector in sheets so
like I mentioned this would be what your
your finance department uses to report
back their spend to the business break
down those costs so really easy tabular
way to do it and that's an example of
way to group by folder there's no reason
you couldn't group by by label as well
or both or both and I include sample
bigquery of what you would put in here
to generate that as well I even did one
that has last month automatically
calculated for you so you don't need to
apply that and it'd be really easy to
just stick it in a sheet and start using
it okay so a single tenant model like
these guys are the easiest to make
decisions for I think meaning we have a
certain amount of resources that are
provisioned every every time we spin up
a customer super obvious that we
probably need to automatically provision
that customer so we build some terraform
scripts we separate out with I am dev
tests and prod perhaps and we deploy a
new project for every customer and we
deploy whatever into that project that
makes the customer go usually the
biggest decision you're gonna make there
is related to networking cannot escape
of this conversation but you know
obviously it's super important every
everybody with a single tenant model
always has some kind of common op system
monitoring security systems those kind
of things that it gets to be tough to
align those costs with with individual
customers they're just kind of a fixed
fee that that our customers have so
generally speaking we don't associate
those costs back to an individual the OP
systems but you can see their individual
project level reporting is sufficient
generally speaking to say how much for
for us
summer a two-run last month is a very
easy thing to search on that's super
obvious just then we do have a lot of
people who try to fit numerous customers
into one project but yet still have a
single tenant system and like our
default would be to recommend not to do
that unless we had a specific reason to
so there's a little bit of you know kind
of conversation that needs to be had
when they're in that spot and try to
figure out why they want to do that but
generally don't be afraid to make
projects right we have customers out
there of hundreds of projects and it's
cool it all fits within the reporting
scheme it doesn't it doesn't cost
anything additional so it's a nice easy
divider there for you to reflect those
costs back alright the big the big the
elephant here right multi tenant multi
tenant systems and how do I use the tool
sets you've showed so far to reflect
back cost per customer and this this is
hard right this isn't this isn't easy at
all
oftentimes it takes a conversation about
what's your architecture right I kind of
see this and I assume we have a gke
strategy but you know not everybody's
there right there's plenty of other
spots to be in for people almost always
I'd say let's let's look at a labeling
strategy the folder idea just kind of
isn't gonna apply here it's not it's not
gonna add a ton of value we might do
both we might do both depending on how
we're using GCP but labels are a better
way to dial in those costs application
level level monitoring is this is the
the of course the best strategy right
for the really large fish they'll be
building in ways to track how much each
customer is using all the different API
api's do tracking back that way maybe
look at transaction costs probably look
at a way to monitor disk and storage
usage so maybe maybe fairly obvious but
use a stack that is friendly for auto
scaling
so that the resources can expand and
contract that applies to everybody but
multi-tenant architectures need to do
that right gke
is by far the most common choice of how
they choose to do that and then and then
looking at monitoring within the
clusters I'm not gonna get into how many
gke clusters should we have here I know
that's like super hotly hotly debated as
to how big we we go with that we know
most people have a namespace strategy to
try to isolate things we know we're
getting more and more comfortable with
bigger clusters but I wouldn't always
assume like let's go with one cluster
and shove everything into it that's not
necessarily the the plan it takes a bit
of a conversation about scale about what
are the different services involved in
almost always is a whiteboard
conversation for us so like I said
multi-tenant cost alignment is very hard
we've got a lot of tools that can help
you here new area is monitoring services
within gke to to try to try to report
back what's happening at that level but
in true multi-tenant we're still gonna
have customers all mixed together
transactions all mixed together and we
need to really build it in the app to
monitor what's going on there so yeah I
can't think of you know you know I think
that's about about all at the high level
that we can give you on the multi-tenant
system be easy enough to build some
reports off of this that that help you
help you see what's happening at the
service level for example so common
recommendations cross across the board
that we have automate provisioning
terraform is something that's comes up
every day in our world provision things
programmatically and then we can make
sure they're put in the right folders we
can make sure they have the right labels
attached and in that the reports are
going to be accurate
another important recommendation is
start your folder design with talking
about I am don't start talk about
reporting right we're approaching it
kind of backwards then we need to make
sure that we're not using folders just
to report on consumption and then we
have a less-than-ideal I
identity access model we need to need to
start by looking at what permissions do
we need to dial and / / folder before we
talk about is that valuable as a rollup
for costs in a combination of labels and
folders is is super common it's not like
this or that we can we can use both
alright so so like I mentioned I have
some example queries out there on github
super big long path we don't have a
million projects on our github though on
our public github so if you go to
github.com slash augusto you will see
you'll see a script to go dump out using
g-cloud commands to dump out what is my
what are my top level folders and what
are their numbers and if I feed at the
right switch I can even generate the
insert syntax to dump that into a table
in bigquery so then the other example
queries that I wrote have have an
assumption that you're gonna have that
table in place so so I made the create
table statement I made I made several
other required things to set it up and
then you can you can use then you can
generate some queries and kind of see
for yourself what the data looks like
and at that point hopefully it's it's
usable to be able to as a building block
for you to start creating your own
reporting like I mentioned I'll try to
add in this afternoon then some links to
the template data studio reports maybe
start with the view that I created in
there you'll see one called view I don't
remember exactly the title of the file
but it's a view and if you save it as a
view you can update estudio to that
instead of the billing data table and it
will pull in your folder names for you
that you can then use to filter so
hopefully that's a starting point for
you to start building some of your own
reporting and and be able to present to
your different different people within
your business what they need so from
there I mean the recommendation is
always talk about who needs to see this
right and try to identify a
of different or groups within your
organization who need a reporting and
then start working with them to see what
what kind of exact data do they need
right so we have standard those standard
Google Data studio templates that we
that we work from and then we add things
all the time right the first one we add
is paid OS for anybody using paid OS as
they kind of need to see that so it's
it's pretty easy to see how that works
once you have the example so whether
you're whether you're a technical person
like that and want to want to dive in or
whether you want to give that to someone
else I think we have a starting spot for
you
[Music]